thomas erber producteurs et coordinateur
de la comptal factory l'intuition qui a
présidé à la création de la factory en
2018 c'est que li na à des clients et
des partenaires qui ont un intérêt fort
pour nos images mais ne savent pas
toujours comment les utiliser quelles
histoires racontées avec nos images et
encore moins comment produire ces
contenus on travail en transversalité
avec les commerciaux du département
marketing avec les équipes du service
culturel beaucoup également avec les
délégations régionales pour inventer
concevoir vendre et puis si on arrive à
vendre produire des contenus sur mesure
pour les clients et partenaires de
l'institut donc ça peut être des grands
musées comme le musée du louvre
des institutions comme le centre
national du livre des collectivités
territoriales des ministères il ça peut
être également des marques du secteur
privé on est haut à la rencontre du
storytelling et de l'écriture
documentaire ont produit des formes
assez variés qui vont de la websérie aux
pastilles réseaux sociaux du brand
contrainte à des contenus muséographique
ou de commémoration ces contenus sont
destinées à être publiées sur les
réseaux sociaux et sites web de nos
partenaires donc leurs marqueurs
commence c'est de devoir répondre en
termes de narration et de formats aux
usages du numérique aujourd'hui on est
assez fiers du projet femmes de paix qu
est une web série
une galerie de portraits de femmes
fortes qui ont oeuvré pour la paix est
un projet qui a été initié avec la
délégation in à lille et que nous avons
produit pour la région normandie dans le
cadre du forum pour la paix
et c'est sans doute cela
l'impressionnant secret de longévité
d'angela davis sa capacité à résister à
tout prix à la violence sans jamais
jamais cessé d'être révolté
on travaille avec le ministère de
l'écologie qui célèbre ses 50 ans
écologie cette année on est également en
discussion avec l'onu pour le forum
génération égalité pour l'égalité femmes
hommes qui va se tenir à paris en juin
prochain donc nous travaillons à des
contenus qui accompagneront le fort